i want to turn the conversation now to a
little covered hearing and the house
homeland security committee
that happened yesterday now the takeaway
from
experts and most of the lawmakers that
were assembled was that this
fight against domestic forces
domestic terrorists extremists would
take
10 to 20 years
now how did they get at that number they
really couldn't say which brings me to
the second
shocking thing about this hearing the
fact that very few republicans
stood up and spoke out against this
insanity
in fact the only one willing to say pump
the brakes
whoa what are you talking about was a
freshman congressman
who's been in office less than one month
do you agree that people can have
differing opinions on issues and
ideologies
but those differences will not affect
the jobs that they do for our country
be it in the military be it in law
enforcement or be it in political office
i fully appreciate and fiercely protect
the right of americans have different
opinions even those that i don't like
but freedom of speech is not the freedom
to commit sedition
i said opinions and ideologies
uh vetting people for ideological
extremism
well that congressman george's andrew
clyde joins me now congressman
it's clear that democrats are trotting
out the so-called
experts to conflate the idea of having
differing opinions
with if you're a conservative and you
supported trump
then you're guilty of sedition and you
should never be heard from again
in public life i found it amazing that
few republicans stood up
except you been been in that town for
one month you still have your integrity
thank you laura i appreciate that um yes
that uh witness was very concerning to
me
in uh in his testimony uh i don't
believe in a political litmus test
you know we all raised our hand to the
same oath of office
to support and defend the constitution
of the united states and as a navy
officer
28 year veteran with combat experience
you know
i defend that first amendment right
for everyone
it's reported tonight that you and
congressman louie gohmert were fined
five thousand dollars for bypassing
house metal detectors a second offense
by the way you're gonna have to sell
your house it's a ten thousand dollar
fine
um that one you a new fan by the way you
didn't know this congressman this was
over at cnn
why oh well thank you andrew clyde of
georgia
and louie gohmert of texas talk about
elitist
too good for safety so much for the
party of law
and order right this is why other
members of congress are scared
who won't go through a security check
what do you got to hide
wait a second mr beefcake over there at
cnn is talking about men being scared
because you're walking in around
your response to that well you know this
is a constitutional issue
those metal detectors are there to uh to
detain us or to
and that's a violation of article 1
section 6 of the constitution
you know we're going to the house floor
to vote we represent 700 000
people in our districts and the
constitution says that we cannot be
impeded
when we go to the florida vote and those
medical congressmen are you going to pay
the
5 000 are you going to pay the 5 000.
i'm going to fight it i'm going to
appeal it and then i'm going to take him
to court because this is
unconstitutional
we're all set up to do that and um but i
had to have standing laura maybe you can
ask nancy if you could borrow some of
her ice cream and sell that for the five
thousand that would probably cover it
but are you gonna do it again because
again it's ten thousand next time it's
like running up the tab here
are you gonna go are you gonna go
through the metal detector next time i
think i've already done it at least a
couple of times that fine was for a
couple of days ago
i've had a couple of uh times since then
i think so i'm probably up to 25 000 by
now
maybe next time detention you'll have to
write it on the board a hundred times i
will not go through the metal detector
congressman thank you so much great to
see you